one thing that we admire about you and
sterling it's effective you guys seem to
juggle of marriage and kids so well I
mean was that ever a challenge for you
figuring out who comes first
yeah the challenge right now is it is
it's a challenge you know and listen
this is a great day and it's a great
moment so everybody's got smiles in the
face I got a smile on my face I made it
you know I don't have any little
handprints on me win but you know every
day every minute is a juggling act you
more for you requires more from you and
so it's true you know it's like there
are moments when there's so much and
you're so blessed and everything's
amazing and then you're like wait a
minute we got to juggle these two kids
you know one quick story my son had to
do a robot for school I am NOT crafty so
I was like that's all you boo
but he came home and he was in tears
like he was really upset and then he was
like my robot looks terrible and all the
other kids had their mom and dad help
and you guys don't care about me you
just care about your career and he just
was crying and I was like we dropped the
robot ball now in his world it was like
such a major thing and when I tell you
we picked that robot ball up and tried
to like hit it out of the park I'm still
not crafty but you know it didn't happen
you may happen but it's moments like
that you know things drop but I think
it's also how you pick them all up I
know it's crazy people are gonna think
it's crazy updates whenever we ever
listen to people you know we have to
talk about this is us because as usual
the emotions are high and I know you've
been on the show but can you talk to me
about sterling in Beth's their back
story is now unfolding with her
childhood where are we gonna pick up D
does he ever spill any tea with you
absolutely
not my husband knows that I am like what
is the opposite of a sponge like I'm
like a sieve I've mutilated that card
the S&L when she's like she can't keep a
secret that is my word vomit yes I'm
totally worth because so he tells me
nothing all I know is that my husband
comes out of his he has a man cave he
comes out his mancave
in tears and he's like because a bird
bird we have a great show like he's just
like wells of emotion with how wonderful
it is so that's all I can tell you you
guys cry he cries - you didn't fail me
mom I'm strong because of you I don't
have you put me on it brought me to
Randall and my girls how did you react
to her you know in some ways giving up
her dreams and now she's focused on her
family like how did that make you feel
when you watch the episodes well you
know I gotta be honest with you it's it
cuts a little close to the bone you know
I think as women we all have that moment
what did what is what did we give up on
that wasn't an essential part of
ourselves and that's the question that
when you kind of sit with that it it
brings up a lot and it takes you through
a lot but on the other side of it is is
a lot of growth but it's it's a hard
that's a hard journey for all but we are
a journey we all have to take
you